the following is a conversation with
dmitry korkin his second time in the
podcast
he's a professor of bioinformatics and
computational biology at wpi
where he specializes in bioinformatics
of complex disease
computational genomics systems biology
and biomedical data analytics
he loves biology he loves computing
plus he is russian and recites a poem in
russian
at the end of the podcast what else
could you possibly
ask for in this world quick mention of
our sponsors
brave browser netsuite business
management software
magic spoon low carb cereal and eight
sleep
self cooling mattress so the choice is
browsing privacy
business success healthy diet or
comfortable sleep
choose wisely my friends and if you wish
click the sponsor links
below to get a discount and to support
this podcast
as a side note let me say that to me the
scientists that did the best
apolitical impactful brilliant work of
2020 are the
biologists who study viruses without an
agenda
without much sleep to be honest just a
pure passion for scientific discovery
and exploration of the mysteries within
viruses
viruses are both terrifying and
beautiful terrifying because they can
threaten the fabric of human
civilization
both biological and psychological
beautiful
because they give us insights into the
nature of life
on earth and perhaps even
extraterrestrial life
of the not so intelligent variety that
might meet us one day
as we explore the habitable planets and
moons in our universe
if you enjoy this thing subscribe on
youtube review it on apple podcast
follow on spotify support on patreon or
connect with me on twitter
at lex friedman and now here's my
conversation
with dmitry korkin it's often
said that proteins and the amino acid
residues that
make them up are the building blocks of
life do you think of proteins in this
way as the
uh basic building blocks of life yes and
no
so the proteins indeed is the the basic
unit biological unit that
carries out uh important functioning of
the cell
however through studying the proteins
and comparing the proteins
across different species across these
different kingdoms
you realize that uh proteins are
actually a more
much more complicated so they
have so-called modular complexity
and so what i mean by that is
an average protein consists of
of several structural units
so we call them protein domains and so
you can imagine a protein
as a string of beads where each bead is
a protein domain
and uh you know in the past
20 years scientists have been studying
uh the nature of the protein domains
because
we realize that it's it's it's the unit
because if you look at the functions
right so so
uh many proteins have more than one
function
and those protein functions uh are often
carried out by those protein domains
so we also see that
in the evolution those proteins domains
get
shuffled so so they act actually as as
the unit
also from the structural perspective
right so you know
some people think of a protein as a sort
of a globular
molecule but as a matter of fact is is
the globular part of this protein
is the protein domain so we we often
have
this uh you know again the the the
collection of this protein domains align
on a string as beads and uh the protein
domains are made up of amino acid
residues so
it's it's so this is the basic build so
you're saying the protein domain
is the basic building block of the
function that we think about
proteins doing so of course you can
always talk about different building
blocks
turtles all the way down but it's
there's a point where there is
at the point of the hierarchy where it's
the most the cleanest
element block
based on which you can put them together
in different kinds of ways
to form complex function and you're
saying protein domains
why is that not talked about as often in
popular
culture well you know there are several
perspectives
on this um and one of course is the
historical perspective right
so historically scientists
have been able to structurally resolved
to obtain the 3d coordinates of
a protein for uh you know for
smaller proteins and smaller proteins
tend to be
a single domain protein so we have a
protein equal to a protein domain and
so so because of that the initial
suspicion was that
the the the proteins are they have
globular shapes
and the more of smaller proteins
you obtain structurally the more you
were
you became convinced that that's that's
the the case
and only later when uh we had
we started having um you know uh
alternative approaches so you know the
the traditional uh the traditional ones
are
x-ray crystallography and nmr
spectroscopy so this is sort of the
the the two main techniques uh
that uh give us the 3d coordinates but
nowadays uh there is huge breakthrough
in
uh cry electron microscopy so the the
more advanced methods that allow us to
uh
you know to get into the uh you know 3d
shapes of much larger molecules
molecular complexes
to give you uh one of the common
examples
uh for this year right so so the the
first
experimental structure of a sars
cove to protein was the cribium
structure
of the s protein so the spike protein
and so it was solved
very quickly and the reason for that is
the
advancement of the uh of this technology
is is pretty spectacular how many
domains does the
uh is it more than one domain oh yes oh
yes i mean so so
it's it's a very complex structure and
we you know on top of the complexity
of a single protein right so this
this structure is actually is a complex
it's a trimer
so it needs to form a trimer in order to
function properly what's a complex
so a complex is agglomeration of
multiple proteins
and so we can have the same
protein copied in multiple uh you know
made up in multiple copies and forming
something that we called uh
a homo oligomer homo means the same
right
so so in this case so uh uh sp the spike
protein is the
is an example of a homo tetramer uh
homotrimer sorry
so these three copies of the three
copies in order to
exactly we have the these three chains
the the three molecular chains uh
coupled uh together and performing the
the function that's what when when you
look at this protein from from the top
you see a perfect triangle
yeah so uh but other uh you know so
other complexes are made up
of um you know different proteins
uh some of them are completely different
some of them are similar the the
hemoglobin molecule right so it's
actually
it's a protein complex it's made of
four basic subunits two of them
uh are identical to each other and two
other identical to each other
but they are also similar to each other
which sort of
uh gives us some ideas about the
evolution of this
uh you know uh of this uh molecule and
uh perhaps so one of the hypothesis is
that you know in the past
it was just a homo tetramer
right so four identical comp uh copies
and then it became
you know uh sort of uh modify
it became mutated over the time and and
became more specialized can we
linger on the spike protein for a little
bit is is there something interesting
or like beautiful you find about it i
mean first of all it's
an incredibly challenging protein and so
we as a part of
uh our sort of research
to understand the structural basis
of this virus to sort of decode
structured decode
every single protein in its proteome
uh which you know we've been working on
the spike uh
protein and uh one of the main
challenges was that
um the cryovm
data allows us to
reconstruct or to obtain the 3d
coordinates of roughly
two thirds of the protein the
rest of the one-third of this protein
it's a part that
uh is buried into the into the membrane
of the virus and uh of the of the
viral envelope and uh it also has a lot
of
unstable structures around it so it's
chemically interacting somehow with
whatever the heck is connecting yeah so
so it people are still trying to
understand so so the the nature of
and the the role of this uh you know uh
of this uh one third because
the the top part uh you know the the
primary function is to get attached to
the
you know h2 receptor human receptor
there is also beautiful you know
mechanics of how this thing happens
right so
because there are three different copies
of this uh
chains or you know there are three
different
domains right so we're talking about
domains so this is the receptor binding
domains rpgs
that gets untangled and
get ready to to to atta to get attached
to
to the receptor and now
they are not necessarily going
in a sync mode as a matter of fact
it's asynchronous yeah so yes so and
this is this is where you know
the another level of complexity comes
into play
because you know right now what we see
is
we typically see just one of the arms
going out and getting ready to to at a
time to be attached to the
uh to the ac2 receptors however
there was a recent mutation that uh
people studied in that spike protein
and a
very recently a group from umass medical
school
uh we happened to collaborate with
groups so this is a group of
jeremy lubin and a number of uh
other faculty um they uh
actually uh solved the uh
the mutated structure of the spike and
they showed that
actually because of these mutations you
have
more than one arms
opening up and so now so you so the
frequency
of two arms going up
increa increase quite you know
drastically how interesting
is that does that change the dynamics
somehow it potentially
can change the dynamics of because now
you have
two possible opportunities to get
attached to the
ac2 receptor it's a very complex
molecular
process mechanistic process but the
first step of this process
is the attachment of this spike protein
of the spike trimer to the
human h2 receptor so this is a molecule
that sits
on the surface of the human cell
and that's essentially what initiates
the what triggers the whole
process of in you know encapsulation if
this was dating this would be the first
date
so this is the uh the way yes
so is it is it possible to have the
spike protein just like floating about
on its own or does it need that
interactive ability with the
uh with the membrane yeah so it needs to
be attached
at least as far as i know but uh you
know when you
get this thing attached on the surface
right there is also a lot of dynamics on
where how it sits on the surface right
so for example
uh there was a recent work in uh again
uh where people use the cry electron
microscopy to get the first glimpse
of the overall structure it's a very low
res but
you still get some interesting details
about this surface about what is
happening inside because we have
literally no clue until
recent work about how the the capsid
is organized so capsid is essentially
it's the inner core of the viral
particle where the uh there is a the
rna of the virus and it's protected by
another protein and protein
that essentially acts as a shield
but you know now we are learning more
and more so
it's actually it's not just this shield
it's you is potentially is used
for the stability of the outer shell of
the
of the virus so it's it's pretty
complicated
and uh i mean understanding all of this
is really useful for trying to figure
out like developing a vaccine or some
kind of
drug to attack any aspects of this right
so i mean there are
many different implications to that i
mean first of all
you know it's it's important to
understand the virus
itself right so you know in order to uh
to understand how it
acts what is the overall mechanism
mechanistic process
of this virus replication of this virus
proliferation to the cell
right so so that's one uh aspect the the
other aspect
is you know designing new treatments
right so one of the
uh possible treatments is uh you know
designing nanoparticles
and so some nanoparticles that will
resemble
the viral shape that would have the
spike integrated
and essentially would act uh as a
competitor to the real virus
by blocking the ace2 receptors
and thus preventing the real virus
entering the cell
now there are also you know there is a
very interesting
direction in looking at the the membrane
at the
envelope portion of the protein and
attacking
its uh m protein so so there are
uh you know to give you a you know sort
of a brief overview
there are four structural proteins these
are the proteins that made up
a structure of the virus
so spike has protein that acts
as a trimer so it needs three copies
e envelope protein that acts as a
pantomer
so it needs five copies to act properly
m uh is a is a membrane protein
at it forms dimers and actually it forms
beautiful lattice and this is something
that we've been studying and we are
seeing it in simulations
it it actually forms a very nice grit or
you know
threads uh you know uh of of different
dimers
attached next to each of copies of each
other and they naturally when you have a
bunch of copies of each other they form
an interesting lattice
exactly and and you know you if you
think about this right so so so
the this complex you know the divi
the viral shape needs to be organized
somehow self-organized somehow
right so it you know if it was a
completely
random process you know you probably
wouldn't have the the
the envelope shell of the so ellipsoid
shape you know you would have something
you know
pretty random right shape so there is
some
you know regularity and how this uh
you know uh how this uh
m dimers get to attach to each other in
a very specific directed way
is that understood at all uh it's not
understood
we are now we we've been working in the
past six months since
you know we met actually this is where
we started working on on trying to
understand the overall
structure of the envelope and the the
key components
that made up this uh you know uh
structure does the envelope also have
the lattice structure
no so so the envelope is essentially is
the outer shell
of the viral particle the n the
nucleocapsid protein
is something that is inside but
get that the n is likely to interact
with
m does it go m and e like where's the e
and
so so e those different proteins
they occur in different copies on the
viral particle so so e this pantomimer
complex we only have two or three
maybe per each particle okay
we have thousand or so of
m dimers that essentially made up uh
that
makes up uh the entire you know
outer shell sure so most of the outer
shell is the m
m dimer and protein when you say
particle that's the viron
the virus the individual single single
element of the virus it's a single virus
single virus
right and we have about you know roughly
50 to 90
spike timers right so so so when you you
know when you
show a per per virus particle per virus
particle
sorry what did you say 50 to 90 50 to 90
right so so this is how this thing is
organized and so now typically right so
you see
this uh uh the the antibodies
that target you know spike proteins
certain parts of the spike protein
but there could be some or also some
treatments right so so these are
you know these are small molecules that
bind strategic parts of these
proteins disrupting its functioning
so one of the promising directions
uh it's one of the newest directions is
actually targeting
the m dimer of the protein
targeting the proteins that make up this
outer shell
because if you are able to destroy the
outer shell
you are essentially destroying the the
the viral particle itself
so preventing it from from you know
functioning
at all so that's you think is uh
from a sort of cyber security
perspective virus security perspective
that's the best attack vector
is uh or like that's a promising attack
vector
i would say yeah so i mean this is still
tons of research needs to be
you know to be done but uh yes i think
you know so there's more attack surface
i guess
more attack surface but you know from
from our analysis from other evolution
analysis
this protein is evolutionary more stable
compared to the say to the spike protein
unstable means a more uh static
target well yeah so so it it it doesn't
change
it doesn't evolve from the evolutionary
perspective
so drastically as for example the spike
protein
there's a bunch of stuff in the news
about mutations of the virus
in the united kingdom i also saw in
south africa
something maybe that was yesterday you
just
kind of mentioned about stability and so
on
which aspects of this are mutatable and
which
aspects if mutated become more dangerous
and maybe even zooming out what are your
thoughts and knowledge and ideas about
the way it's mutated all the news that
we've been hearing are you worried about
it
from a biological perspective are you
worried about it from a human
perspective
so i mean you know mutations are sort of
a general way for these viruses to
evolve
right so so it's you know it's uh
essentially this is the way they evolve
this is
the way they were able to jump
from you know one species to another
we also see uh you know some
recent jumps there were some incidents
of this virus jumping from human to dogs
so you know there is some danger in in
in in those jobs because you know every
time it jumps it also mutates
right so so it when it jumps to
to the uh to the species and jumps back
right so it acquires some mutations that
are sort of
um driven by the
environment of a new host yeah right and
it's different
from the human environment and so we
don't know whether the mutations that
are required
uh in the new species are neutral
with respect to the human host or maybe
you know maybe um damaging yeah change
is always scary
but so you worried about i mean it seems
like because the spread is
during winter niles seems to be
exceptionally high
uh and especially with a vaccine just
around the corner already being actually
deployed there's some worry that there's
this puts evolutionary pressure
selective pressure on the virus
afford to uh to mute for you to mutate
is that us yeah well i mean there is
always this thought
you know in in in the scientists my mind
you know what happened what will happen
right so
uh i know they've been uh they've been
discussions about
sort of the arms race between the you
know the ability
of of the uh of the you know humanity to
uh you know to get vaccinated faster
then the virus you know uh essentially
you know becomes uh you know resistant
to to the vaccine
um i i mean
i don't worry that much
uh simply because uh you know there is
not that much evidence to that to
aggressive mutation around the vaccine
exactly you know obviously there are
mutations around the works
there are vaccines so the reason we get
vaccinated
every year against the season of
mutations
right um but uh
you know i think it's important to study
it
no doubts right so i think one of the
you know to me and again i might be
biased
uh because you know we we've been uh
trying
to to do that as well uh so but one of
the critical directions
in understanding the virus is to uh to
understand its evolution
in order to uh sort of understand the
mechanisms the key mechanisms that
lead the virus to jump you know the
nordic viruses to jump from
species from species to another that
the mechanisms that lead the virus to
become
resistant to accidents also to
treatments
right and hopefully that knowledge was
uh will
enable us to sort of forecast the
evolutionary
uh traces the future evolutionary traces
of those virus
i mean what uh from a biological
perspective this might be a dumb
question but is there
parts of the virus that if uh
souped up like through mutation
could make it more effective at doing
its job we're talking about the specific
coronavirus like yeah because we were
talking about the different like the
membrane
the m protein the e protein the n
and the s the spike
is there some there are 20 or so more
in addition to that but is that is that
a dumb way to look at it like
uh which of these if mutated
could have the greatest impact
potentially
damaging impact on the effectiveness of
the virus so it's actually it's it's a
very good question
because and and the short answer is we
don't know yet
but uh of course there is capacity of
this virus to
to become more efficient the reason for
that
is um you know so if you look at the
virus i mean it's it's a machine right
so it's a machine that
does a lot of different functions and
many of these functions are sort of
nearly perfect but they are not perfect
and
those mutations can make those functions
more perfect for example
the attachment to ace2 receptor right of
the spike
right so uh you know
is it has this virus reached
the efficiency in which the attachment
is carried out or there are some
mutations that
uh that still to be discovered right
that will
make this attachment uh sort of
stronger or you know
something uh more in a way more
efficient
from the point of view of this virus
functioning
that's that's sort of the obvious
example but
if you look at each of these proteins i
mean it's there for a reason it performs
certain function
and it could be that
certain mutations will you know enhance
this function
it could be that some mutations will
make this function
much less efficient right so that's
that's also the case
let's uh since we're talking about the
evolutionary history of a virus uh
let's zoom back out and uh
look at the evolution of proteins i i
glanced at this 2010 nature paper
on the quote ongoing expansion of the
protein universe
and then you know it kind of implies
and uh talks about that uh protein
started with a common ancestor which is
you know kind of interesting it's
interesting thing about like even just
like the first
organic thing that started life on earth
and from that there's now uh you know
what is it 3.5 billion years later
there's now millions of proteins
and they're still evolving and that's
you know in part one of the things that
you're researching
is there something interesting to you
about the evolution
of proteins from this initial ancestor
to today is there something beautiful
insightful about this
long story so i think you know uh if
if i were to pick a single keyword
about uh protein evolution i would pick
modularity something that we talked
about uh
in the in the beginning and that's the
fact that
the proteins are no longer considered
as you know as a sequence of letters
there are hierarchical uh complexities
in the way these proteins are organized
and uh
this complexities are actually going
beyond
the protein sequence it's actually going
all the way back to the
uh to the gene to the nucleotide
sequence
and so you know again these
protein domains they are not only
functional building blocks they are also
evolutionary building blocks
and so what we see in the sort of in the
later stages of evolution
i mean once this stable structurally and
functionally
building blocks were discovered they
essentially
they stay those domains stay
as such so that's why if you start
comparing
different proteins you will see that
many of them
will have similar fragments and those
fragments will correspond to something
that we call
protein domain families and so so they
are still different because you you
still have
mutations and and and and you know
the you know different mutations
are attributed to to you know
diversification of the function
of this uh you know uh protein domains
however
you don't you very rarely see um
you know the the evolutionary events
that would split this domain
into fragments because and it's you know
once you have the the the the domain
split you actually you uh you know
you can completely cancel out its
function
or at the very least you can reduce it
and that's not
you know efficient from the point of
view of the you know of the
cell functioning so so the
the protein domain level is a very
important one
now on top of that right so
if you look at the proteins right so you
have this structural units
and they carry out the function but then
much less is known about things that
connect this
protein domains something that we call
linkers
and those linkers are completely
flexible
you know parts of the protein that
nevertheless carry out
a lot of function it's like little tails
little heads
so so we we do have tails so they called
termini
c and and terminus so these are things
right on the on
on on one and
another ends of the protein sequence so
they are also very important so they
they attribute it to
very specific uh interactions between
the proteins
so but you're referring to the links
between domains
that connect the domains and you know
apart from the just the the uh
simple perspective if you have you know
a very short domain
you have sorry a very short linker you
have two domains
next to each other they are forced to be
next to each other if you have a very
long one
you have the domains that are extremely
flexible
and they carry out a lot of sort of pa
spatial
reorganization right so but
on top of that right just this linker
itself
because it's so flexible it actually can
adapt to a lot of different shapes and
therefore
it's a it's a very good interactor when
it comes to interaction between
this protein and other protein all right
so these things also evolve
you know uh and they in a way
have different law uh sort of uh uh laws
of
uh or the driving laws that
underlie the the evolution because they
no longer need to
uh to preserve certain structure
right uh unlike protein domains and so
now
on top of that you have uh something
that is
even less studied and this is something
that uh
uh attribute to to the concept of
alternative splicing so alternative
splicing so
it's a it's a very cool concept it's
something that uh
uh we've been fascinated about for you
know over a decade
uh in my lab and trying to do research
with that
but so you know so so typically you know
a simplistic
perspective is that one gene is equal
one protein product right so you have a
gene
you know you transcribe it and and
translate it and you
it becomes a protein in reality
when we talk about eukaryotes especially
sort of
more recent eukaryotes that are very
complex
the gene is not it's no longer equal to
one protein it actually can
uh produce multiple
functionally uh you know active
protein products and each of them is
you know is called an alternatively
spliced product
the reason it happens is that if you
look at the gene
it actually has it has also blocks
and the blocks some of which and it
it's essentially it goes like this so we
have a block that will later be
translated we call it exon
then we'll have a block that is not
translated cut out
we call it intron so we have exon intron
exon intro et cetera et cetera et cetera
right so
sometimes you can have uh you know
dozens of these
exons and introns so what happens is
during the the process when the gene is
converted
to rna we have
things that are cut out the introns that
cut out and exons that now get assembled
together
and sometimes we will throw out
some of the exons and the remaining
protein products will become still be
the same different or different right so
so now you have
uh fragments of the protein that no
longer there
they were cut out with the introns
sometimes
you will essentially take one exam and
replace it with another one
right so there's some flexibility in in
this process
so so that creates a whole new level of
complexity
because it's random though is it random
it's it's not random we
and and this is where i think uh now the
the appearance of this modern uh single
cell
uh and and before that tissue
level sequencing next generation
sequencing techniques such as rna-seq
allows us to see that this these are the
events
that often happen in response in it's a
it's a dynamic event
that happens in response to to
disease or in response to certain
developmental stage
of a cell and and this is an incredibly
complex layer that also
undergoes i mean because it's at the
gene level right so it undergoes certain
evolution right and uh
now we have this interplay between
what's happening and what is happening
in the
in the protein world and what is
happening in the
in the gene and you know rna world
and for example you know it's
it's often that we see that the
boundaries of this exons
coincide with the boundaries of the
protein domains
right so there is this you know close
interplay to that
uh it's not always i mean you know
otherwise it would be too simple right
but we do see the connection between
those
sort of machineries and obviously the
evolution
will pick up this complexity and
uh you know select for whatever is
successful
we see that complexity in play and and
makes this question you know more
complex but more exciting
as a small detour i don't know if you
think about this in
into the world of computer science
there's uh
douglas house that or i think came up
with a
name of quine which are i don't know if
you're familiar with these things but
it's computer programs
that have uh i guess exxon and intron
and they copy the whole purpose of the
program is to copy itself
so it prints copies of itself but can
also carry information inside of it
so it's a very kind of crude fun
exercise
of um can we sort of replicate these
ideas from cells
can we have a computer program that when
you run it
just prints itself the entirety of
itself
and does it in different programming
languages and so on i've been playing
around and
writing them it's a kind of fun little
exercise you know when i was a kid
so so you know it it was essentially one
of the
of the sort of main stages
in in informatics olympiads
that you have to reach in order to be
any so good
is you should be able to write a program
that
replicates itself and so the tax then
becomes
even you know sort of more complicated
so what is the shortest
what is the sure program yeah and of
course it's it's you know it's a
function of a programming language
but yeah i remember you know long long
long time ago
when we tried to you know to to make it
short and short and find the the
the shortcut there's actually on a stack
exchange there's a
entire site called code golf
i think where the entirety is just a
competition
people just come up with whatever task i
don't know
like uh write code that reports the
weather today
and the competition is about whatever
programming language what is the
shortest program
and it makes you actually people should
check it out because it makes you
realize there's some
some weird programming languages out
there but
you know just to dig on that a little uh
deeper uh do you think
you know in computer science we don't
often think about
programs just like the machine learning
world now
uh that's still kind of basic
programs and then there's humans that
replicate themselves
right and there's these mutations and so
on
do you think we'll ever have a world
where there's programs that kind of
have an evolutionary process so i'm not
talking about evolutionary algorithms
but i'm talking about programs that kind
of
mate with each other and evolve and like
on their own replicate themselves
so this is kind of the idea here
is you know that's how you can have a
runaway
thing so we think about machine learning
as a system that gets smarter and
smarter and smarter and smarter
at least the machine learning systems of
today are
like it's it's a program that you can
like turn off
as opposed to throwing a bunch of little
programs out there and letting them
like multiply and mate and evolve and
replicate
do you ever think about that kind of
world you know when we jump from the
biological
systems that you're looking at to to
artificial ones i mean it's
almost like you you take the the sort of
the area of intelligent agents
right which are essentially the the
independent sort of uh
codes that run and interact and exchange
the information
right so i i don't see why not i mean i
you know it could be sort of a natural
evolution in in
in this you know uh area of computer
science
i think it's kind of an interesting
possibility it's terrifying too
but i think it's a really powerful tool
like to have like agents that inter
you know we have social networks with
millions of people and they interact
i think it's interesting to inject into
that was already injected into that bots
right but those bots are pretty dumb uh
uh
you know they're they're probably pretty
dumb algorithms
uh you know it's interesting to think
that
there might be bots that evolve together
with humans and there's the sea of
humans
and robots that are operating first in
the digital space
and then you can also think i love the
idea some people worked i think
at harvard at penn there's uh
robotics labs that you know build
take as a fundamental task to build a
robot that given
extra resources can build another copy
of itself
like in the physical space which is uh
super
difficult to do but super interesting i
remember there's like research on
robots that can build a bridge so they
make a copy of themselves and they
connect themselves and
sort of like self-building bridge based
on building blocks you can imagine like
a building that self-assembles so it's
basically self-assembling structures
from uh
from uh robotic parts but it's
interesting
to within that robot add the ability to
mutate and
uh and and do all the interesting
like little things that you're referring
to in evolution to go from a single
origin protein building block to like
well weird complexity and if you think
about this i mean you know the bits and
pieces
are there you know so so you mentioned
revolutionary algorithm right you know
so this is sort of yeah
and the the maybe sort of the the goal
is in a way different right so the goal
is to you know to essentially
uh to to optimize your search right so
uh but uh sort of the the ideas are
there so you people recognize that you
know that the
the you know recombination events
lead to global changes in the in in
search trajectories the mutations event
is a more refined
uh you know uh step in in the search
then you have you know uh other sort of
uh nature inspired algorithm right so
one of the reason that
that you know i think it's it's one of
the funnest one is the slime
uh based algorithm right so that it's a
i think the first was introduced by the
japanese
group but where it was able to to solve
uh some some pre you know complex
problems
uh so so that's the yeah and and then
i think uh there are still
a lot of things we've yet to to
you know borrow from the nature right so
there are
a lot of sort of ideas that nature
uh you know gets to offer us that
you know it's up to us to grab it and to
to
to you know get the best use of it
including neural networks
you know we have a very crude inspire
inspiration from nature on neural
networks maybe there's
other inspirations to be discovered in
the brain or
other aspects of uh the various systems
even like the immune system the way it
uh interplays
i recently started to understand that
like the immune system has something to
do with the way the brain
operates like there's multiple things
going on in there
which uh all of which are not modeled in
artificial neural networks
and maybe if you throw a little bit of
that biological spice in there
you'll come up with something uh
something cool i i
i'm not sure if you're familiar with the
drake equation
that uh estimate i just did a video on
it yesterday because i wanted to give my
own estimate of it
it's uh it's an equation that combines a
bunch of factors to estimate how many
alien civilizations oh yeah i've heard
about it
yes so one one of the interesting
parameters you know it's like
how many uh stars are born every year
how many planets are on average per star
uh for this how many habitable planets
are there
and then the the one that starts being
really interesting
is uh the probability that life emerges
on a habitable planet so like
i don't know if you think about you
certainly think a lot about evolution
but do you think about the thing
which evolution doesn't describe which
is like the beginning of evolution
the origin of life i think i put the
probability of life developing a
habitable planet
one percent this is very scientifically
uh rigorous
okay uh well first at a high level for
the drake equation what would you put
that percent that
on earth and in general do you have
something
do you have thoughts about how life
might have started
you know like the proteins being the
first kind of one of the early
jumping points yes so so um i think
back in 2018 there was a very exciting
paper published in nature
where they uh found
uh one of the simplest amino acids
glycine
in this in a comet dust
so so this is uh and i i
i apologize if i uh don't pronounce it's
a
russian named comets it's i think to
grim of gerasimenko
this is the comment where and there was
this uh
um mission to to get and uh
get close to this comment and get the
the
stardust from from its tail and
uh when scientists analyzed it they
actually found
traces of uh you know uh
of glycine which you know makes up you
know the
one it's one of the basic uh one of the
20 basic
uh amino acids that makes up proteins
right so uh so that was exciting very
exciting
right but you know it's the question is
very interesting right so
what uh you know what if there is some
alien life
is it gonna be made of proteins right or
maybe
rnas right so we see that you know the
the
rna viruses are certainly you know
very well established sort of uh
you know group of molecular machines
right so um so yeah it's it's it's a
very
interesting question you know what what
probability would you put like how hard
is this
job like how unlikely just on earth do
you think this whole thing is
that we got going like is that are we
really lucky or is it
inevitable like what's your sense when
you sit back and think about
life on earth is it higher or lower than
one percent
well because one percent is pretty low
but it still is like damn that's pretty
good chance
yes it's it's a pretty good chance i
mean i i would
personally but again you know i'm um
you know probably not the best person to
to
to do such estimations but uh
i would you know intuitively i would
probably put it
lower yeah but still i mean you know
we're really lucky
here on earth uh i mean or the
conditions are really good
it means you know i think that there was
everything was
right in a way right so it's still it's
not
the the conditions were not like ideal
if you
try to to look at you know what was you
know
several billions years ago when the life
emerged
so there is something called uh the rare
earth hypothesis
that you know encounter to the drake
equation says that
the you know the conditions of earth if
you actually were to describe
earth it's quite a special place
so special might be unique in our galaxy
and potentially you know close to unique
in the entire universe like it's very
difficult to reconstruct those
same conditions and what the rare earth
hypothesis
argues is all those different conditions
are essential for life
and so that's the sort of the counter
you know like all the things we
thinking that earth is pretty average um
i mean i can't really
i'm trying to remember to to go through
all of them but just the fact that it um
is shielded from a lot of asteroids
the obviously the distance to the sun
but also the fact that it's
um it's like a perfect balance between
the amount of water and land and all
those kinds of things and
i don't know there's a bunch of
different factors that i remember
there's a long list
but it's fascinating to think about if
if uh
in order for something like proteins and
then
dna and rna to emerge you need um
and basic living organisms you need
to be a very close and earth-like planet
which would be sad or
exciting i don't know which uh if you
ask me i you know
in a way i put a parallel between um
you know between our own research uh
and i mean from the
from the intuitive perspective you know
you have those
two extremes and the reality is never
very rarely falls into the extremes
it's always the optimus always reached
somewhere in between
so so i would so and that's what i tend
to think i think that
uh you know we're probably somewhere in
between so they were
not unique unique but
again the chances are you know
reasonably small
the problem is we don't know the the
other extreme is like
i tend to think that we don't actually
understand the basic mechanisms of like
what this is all originated from like it
seems like
we think of life as this distinct thing
maybe intelligence is a distinct thing
maybe the physics that from which
planets and suns are born is a distinct
thing but that could be a very
it's like the stephen wolfram thing it's
like the from simple rules emerges
greater and greater complexity
so i you know i tend to believe that
just life finds a way
it like we don't know the extreme of how
common life is
because it could be life is like
everywhere
like like so everywhere that it's almost
like
laughable like that we're such idiots to
think where you
like it's it's like ridiculous to even
like think
it's like ants thinking that their
little colony is the
unique thing and everything else doesn't
exist i mean
it it's also very possible that that's
uh
that's the extreme and we're just not
able to maybe comprehend
the nature of that uh life just to stick
on alien life for just a brief
moment more is there is some signs of
signs of life on venus in gaseous form
there's uh hope for life
on mars probably extinct we're not
talking about intelligent life
although that has been in the news
recently we're talking about basic like
you know uh bacteria bacteria yeah
and then also i guess uh there's a
couple moons
there yeah your europa which is
jupiter's moon i think there's another
one
are you um is that exciting or is it
terrifying to you that
we might find life do you hope we find
life i certainly
do hope that we'll find life um i mean
it was very exciting to
to hear about uh you know uh this
uh news about the the
possible life on the venus it'd be nice
to have hard evidence
of something with uh which is what the
hope is for
for mars and and uh europa but do you
think those organisms would be similar
biologically or would they even be sort
of carbon based
if we do find them i would say they
they would be carbon based uh how
similar
it's a big question right so it's it's
the moment we discover things
outside earth right even if it's a tiny
little
single cell i mean there's so much
just imagine that that would be so i i
think that that would be
another turning point for for the
science you know and if especially if
it's
different in some very new way that's
exciting because that says
that's a definitive state not a
definitive but a pretty strong statement
that life is everywhere in the in the
in the universe to me at least that's
that's really exciting
you brought up joshua letterberg in an
offline conversation
i think i'd love to talk to you about
affifold and this might be an
interesting way to
enter that conversation because uh so he
won the
1958 nobel prize in physiology medicine
for discovering that bacteria can mate
and exchange genes
but uh he also did a ton of other stuff
like uh like we mentioned helping nasa
find life on mars and uh
the uh the dendro
the the chemical expert system expert
systems remember those
uh do you uh what do you find
interesting
about this guy and his his ideas about
artificial intelligence in general
so i have a kind of personal story
to um to share so i
started my phd in canada back in 2000
and so essentially my pg was uh so we
were
developing sort of a new language for
symbolic uh machine learning
so it's different from the feature based
machine learning and and the
uh one of the sort of cleanest
applications of this
uh you know of this approach of this
formalism
was uh two uh chem informatics and
computer aided drug design
right so so so essentially we were uh
you know as a part of my research
uh i developed a system that
essentially looked at chemical compounds
of say the same therapeutic category
you know male hormones right
and tried to figure out
the structural fragments that are the
structural building blocks
that are important that define this
class
versus structural building blocks that
are there just because
you know the to complete the structure
but they are not essentially the ones
that make up the
the chemical the the key chemical
properties of this uh
therapeutic category and and uh
you know uh for me it was something new
i was i was trained as an applied
mathematician
you know as with some a machine learning
background but you know computer
drug design was completely a completely
new territory
so because of that i often uh find
myself
asking lots of questions uh on one of
these sort of central uh
forums back then there were no no
facebooks or stuff like that there was a
forum
you know it's a forum it's essentially
it's like a bulletin board
yeah right yeah so you essentially you
have a bunch of people and you post a
question
and you get you know an answer from you
know different people
and and and back then this one of the
most popular uh forums was
ccl i think um computational chemistry
libra not library but something like
that but ccl
that was the the forum and there i i
you know i asked a lot of dumb questions
yes i ask questions
also share some some you know some uh
information about our former is and how
we do and whether
whatever we do makes sense and so you
know and
uh i remember that well one of this
posts i mean i still remember
you know uh i uh i would call it
desperately looking for uh for uh
a chemist advice something like that
right and so so i post my
question i explained you know how how my
uh
our formalism is what is what it does
and what kind of applications i'm
planning to
to do and you know and it was you know
in the middle of the night
and you know i went back uh you know to
bed
and and next morning have a
phone call from my advisor who also
looked at this forum it's like
you won't believe who replied to you
and and it's like who he said well you
know
there is a message to you from joshua
lederberg
and my reaction was like who is joshua
later back
your eyes are hung up so
and essentially you know joshua wrote me
that
we we had conceptually similar ideas in
in the dandruff
project you may want to look it up
[Music]
and you know we should also sorry and
it's a side comment say that
even though he he won the nobel prize at
a really young age
in 58 but so he he was i think
he was what 33 yeah it's just crazy yeah
so anyway so that's so hence hence in
the 90s
responding to young whippersnappers on
the on the ccl forum
okay and and so so back then he was
already very senior i mean
he unfortunately passed away back in
2008
uh but you know uh back in 2001 he was i
mean he was a professor emeritus at
rockefeller university and you know that
was actually believe it or not one of
the
one of the uh of uh of the reasons
i decided to join uh you know as a
postdoc
the group of andrei saleh who was at
rockefeller university
with the hope that you know that i could
actually you know
uh have a chance uh to meet joshua in
person
and i met him very briefly right the you
know
just because he was walking you know
there's a little breach that connects
the sort of the
research campus with the um
with the uh sort of sky scrapper that
rockefeller
owns the where you know uh post docs and
faculty and
graduate students live and so so i met
him you know and i had a
very short conversation you know but uh
so i i started you know reading about
dandrull
and i was amazed you know it's we're
talking about 1960
yeah right the ideas
were so profound well what's the
fundamental ideas of it
the the reason to make this is even
crazier
so so so leatherberg wanted to make a
system
that would help him study
the extraterrestrial
molecules right so so the idea was that
you know the way you study the
extraterrestrial molecules is you do the
mass spec
analysis right and so the mass spec
gives you sort of bits numbers about
essentially uh
gives you the ideas about the possible
fragments
or you know atoms and you know and and
and maybe little fragments pieces of
this molecule
that make up the molecule right so now
you need to
sort of to decompose this information
and to figure out what was the whole
before you know it beca became uh
fragments bits and pieces right so so
in order to make this uh you know to
have this
tool the idea of leather work was to
connect
chemistry computer science
and to design this so-called expert
system
that looks that takes into account this
it takes as an
input the mass pack data
the possible the database of possible
molecules and essentially try to
uh sort of induce the molecule that
would correspond to this spectra or you
know
essentially the what this
project ended up being
was that you know it would provide a
list of candidates
that then a chemist would look at and
and and
make final decision so but the original
idea is supposed to solve the entirety
of this problem
automatically yes so so so he uh you
know so uh
so he uh back then uh he
succeeded yes believe that
yeah it's it's amazing i mean it still
blows my mind you know that
it's that's is and this was essentially
the the
the origin of the modern bioinformatics
game informatics
you know back in the 60s yeah right so
that's that's you know
you know so every time you you you deal
with
with projects like this with the you
know research like this
you just you know uh so the the power
of of the of the you know intelligence
of this
people uh is is just you know
overwhelming do you think about expert
systems
is there um and why they kind of didn't
become successful especially in the
space of bioinformatics
where it does seem like there's a lot of
expertise in humans
and uh you know it's it's possible to
see that
a system like this could be made very
useful
right so it's it's actually it's a it's
a great question and and this is
something so you know so
uh you know at my university i teach
artificial intelligence and you know we
start the my first two lectures are on
the history of ai
and and there we you know we tried to
you know go through the main stages of
ei and so you know the question of why
expert systems failed
or became obsolete it's actually a very
interesting
one and there are you know if you uh try
to read the
you know the historical perspectives
there are actually two lines of thoughts
one is that the they were
uh essentially not
up to the expectations and so therefore
they were replaced you know uh by by
other
things right the other one
was that uh completely opposite one that
they were
too good and and as a result
they essentially became sort of a
household name and
then essentially they they got
transformed
i mean the in both cases sort of the
outcome was the same they evolved into
something
yeah right and that's what i you know if
if i look at this right so the modern
machine learning
right so those echoes in in the modern
machine learning i think so
i think so because you know if if you
think about this you know and how we
design
uh you know uh the most successful
algorithms including alpha fault right
you built in the knowledge about the
domain
uh that you study all right so so you
built in your expertise
so speaking of alpha fold the deep minds
alpha fold
two recently uh was announced to have
quote unquote
solved protein folding how exciting is
this to you
it seems to be one of the one of the
exciting things that have happened in
2020 it's an incredible accomplishment
from the looks of it
what part of it is amazing to you what
part would you say is
over hype or maybe misunderstood
it's definitely a very exciting
achievement to give you
a little bit of perspective right so uh
so in bioinformatics
we have several competitions and so
the way you know you often hear uh
how those competitions have been
explained to uh sort of to
known bioinformaticians is that you know
they call it bioinformatics olympic
games
and there are several disciplines right
so so the was so the the historical one
of the first one
was the discipline in predicting the
protein structure
predicting the 3d coordinates of the
proteins but there are some other so
uh the predicting protein functions uh
predicting
effects of uh mutations on protein
functions
then uh predicting uh protein protein
interactions
so so the original one was uh casp
or a critical assessment of uh of
protein structure um
and um the
you know typically what uh happens
during these competitions
is uh you know scientists experimental
scientists
solve the these structures but don't put
them
into the protein data bank which is the
centralized
database that contains all the 3d
coordinates
instead they hold it and release
protein sequences and now the challenge
of the community is to predict
the 3d structures of these proteins and
then
use the experimental resolve structures
to assess which one
is the closest one right and this
competition by the way just a bunch of
different tangents and maybe you can
also say what is protein folding
uh and this competition casp competition
is
has become the gold standard and that's
what was used to say that protein
folding was solved so i used to add a
little
um yeah just a bunch so if you could
whenever you say stuff
maybe throw in some of the basics for
the folks that might be outside of the
field
anyway sorry so so yeah so you know so
the reason it's it's
um you know it's relevant to
our understanding of protein folding is
because
you know we we we've yet to learn
how the folding mechanistically works
right so there are different hypotheses
what happens to this fault for example
uh there is a hypothesis that
the folding happens by you know in also
in the modular fashion right so that
you know we have protein domains that
get folded
independently because their structure is
stable and then
the whole protein structure gets formed
but you know
within those domains we also have uh
so-called secondary structure the small
alpha helices beta sheets so these are
you know uh
uh elements that are structurally stable
and so and the the question is you know
when they when do they get formed
because some of the secondary structure
elements
you have to have uh you know a fragment
in the beginning and say they're
fragment in the middle
right so so you cannot potentially start
having a the the full fault from the
get-go
right uh so so it's still you know it's
still a big enigma
what what happens we know that it it's
an extremely
efficient and stable process right so
there's this long sequence
and the fold happens really quickly
exactly well that's really weird right
and it happens like the same way almost
every time exactly exactly right really
weird
so that's freaking weird it's it's yeah
that's that's why it's it is it's such a
mega it's amazing
but most importantly right so it's you
know so when when you see the
the the you know the translation process
right so
when you don't have the the the whole
uh protein translated
right it's still being translated you
know uh
getting out from the ribosome you you
already see some structural
you know fragmentation so so folding
starts happening before the whole
protein gets produced
right and so this is this is obviously
you know one of the
biggest questions in you know in modern
molecular biology
not not like maybe what happens like
that's not
that's bigger than the question of
folding that's the question of like
like deeper fundamental idea of folding
yes
behind folks exactly exactly so you know
so obviously
if we are able to uh
predict the end product
of protein folding we are one step
closer
to understanding sort of the
mechanistics of the protein folding
because we can then potentially look and
and start probing
what are the critical parts of this
process and what are
not so critical parts of this process so
we can start decomposing
this you know so so so in the way this
protein structure prediction algorithm
can be
can be used as a tool right so so
you change the the the you know you
modify the the
protein you get back to to this tool
it predicts okay it's completely it's
completely unstable yeah which
uh which aspects of the input will have
a big impact on the output
exactly exactly so so what happens is
you know we typically have some sort of
incremental
uh advancement you know each stage of
this
cusp competition you have groups with
incremental advancement
and you know historically uh the top
performing groups
were uh you know they were not
using machine learning they were using
uh very advanced biophysics
combined with bioinformatics combined
with you know the the data mining
uh and that was uh you know that
would enable them to obtain uh
protein structures of those proteins
that don't have any structurally soft
relatives
because you know if we have
another protein say the same protein but
coming from a different species
we could potentially derive some ideas
and that's so-called homology or
comparative modeling
where we'll derive some ideas from the
previously known structures
and that would help us tremendously in
uh you know in uh reconstructing the 3d
structure
uh overall but what happens when we
don't have these relatives this is when
it becomes
really really hard right so that's
so-called de novo
uh uh you know uh the nova protein
structure prediction
and in this case those methods were uh
traditionally very good but what
happened in the
in the last year the original alpha
fault
came into and over sudden
it's much better than everyone else
this is 2018. yeah oh the competition is
only every two years um
i think and and then so uh
you know it was sort of kind of of a
shock wave to
to to to the bioinformatics community
that you know we have
like a state-of-the-art machine learning
system
that does uh you know structure
prediction and
and essentially what it does you know so
you know if you look at this it actually
predicts the context
so you know so so the the process of
reconstructing the
the 3d structure starts by predicting
the
the context between the different parts
of the
protein and the context essentially the
parts of the proteins that are in a
close proximity to each other
right so actually the machine learning
part seems to be
estimating you can correct me uh if i'm
i'm wrong here but it seems to be
estimating the distance matrix which is
like
the distance between the different parts
yeah so we call the contact map
contact map right so once you have the
contact map the reconstruction
is becoming more straightforward yeah
right but so the contact map is the key
and so so uh you know so that
what happened and uh now we started
seeing in this current
stage right where in the in the most
recent one
we started seeing the emergence of these
ideas
in others people works right
but yet is you know alpha fault two
yeah that again outperforms everyone
else
and also by introducing yet another wave
of of the
of the you know machine learning ideas
yeah uh they don't seem to be also an
incorporation first of all this the
paper is not out yet but there's a bunch
of ideas already out
there does seem to be an incorporation
of this other thing
i don't know if it's something that you
could speak to which is like
the incorporation of like other
structures like evolutionary similar
yes structures that are used to kind of
give you hints
yes so so so the evolutionary similarity
uh is something that we can detect at
different levels right so
we know for example that this structure
of proteins is more conserved than the
sequence
the sequence could be very different but
the structural shape
is actually still very conserved so
that's that's sort of the intrinsic
property that
you know in a way related to protein
folds you know to the evolution
of the you know of the protein of
proteins and protein domains etc
but we know that i mean we they've been
multiple studies
and uh you know ideally if you have
structures
you know you should use that information
however sometimes we don't have this
information instead we have
a bunch of sequences sequences we have a
lot right so so we
we have you know hundreds
thousands of uh you know different
organisms
sequenced right and by taking this same
protein
but in different organisms and
aligning it so making it you know
making the corresponding positions
aligned
we can actually uh say a lot
about sort of what is conserved in this
protein
and therefore you know structurally more
stable what is diverse in these proteins
so on top of that we we could provide
sort of the information about the
sort of the secondary structure of this
protein et cetera so this information is
extremely useful and it's already there
so so while it's tempting to you know to
do
a complete ab initio so you just have a
protein sequence and nothing else
the reality is such that we we are
overwhelmed with this data
so why not use it and
so yeah so i i'm looking forward to to
reading the the this paper
it does seem to like they've in the
previous version of alpha fold they
didn't
uh for this the evolutionary similarity
thing they didn't use machine learning
for that or they rather they used it as
like the input to the entirety of the
the neural net
like the features uh derived from the
similarity
it seems like there's some kind of
quote-unquote iterative thing
where it seems to be part of the
part of the learning process is the
incorporation of this
evolutionary similarity yeah i i don't
think there is a bioarchive paper right
there's no no
there's nothing yeah it's a blog post
that's written by a marketing team
essentially
yeah which you know it has some
scientific uh
uh similarity probably to
the the actual methodology used but it
could be
it's like interpreting scripture it
could it could be just
poetic uh interpretations of the actual
work as opposed to direct connection to
the work
so now speaking about protein folding
right so so so you know in order to
answer the question whether or not we we
have solved this
right yeah so we need to go back to to
the beginning of our conversation
you know with the realization that you
know an average protein is
that typically what uh the the cusp
uh has been focusing on is uh the
you know this competition has been
focusing on the single
maybe two domain proteins that are still
very compact
and even those ones are extremely
challenging to to solve
right but now we talk about you know an
average protein that has two three
protein domains
if you look at the um proteins that uh
that are in charge of the you know of
the process
in you know with the neural system right
perhaps one of the uh of the
most recently evolved sort of uh
systems in in in a in an organism
right all of them well the majority of
them
are highly multi-domain proteins so they
are
you know some of them have five six
seven
you know and more domains right
and you know we are very far away from
understanding how these proteins are
folded
so the complexity of the protein matters
here the complexity the
complexity of the protein modules or the
the protein domains
so you're saying solve so the definition
of solved here is
particularly the cast competition
achieving human level
not human level achieving uh mental
experimental level performance
on these particular sets of proteins
that have been used in these
competitions well i mean
you know i i i do think that uh
you know especially with with regards to
the alpha fault
you know it is able to uh you know
to solve you know at the
near experimental level a
pretty big majority of the of the
uh more compact proteins like or protein
domains because
again in order to understand how the
overall protein uh
you know multi-domain protein fold we do
need to understand
the structure of its individual domains
i mean unlike
if you look at alpha zero or like even
mu0
if you look at that work you know there
it's nice reinforcement learning
self-playing mechanisms are nice because
it's all in simulation so you can
learn from just huge amounts like you
don't need data
like the problem with proteins like the
size
uh i forget how how many 3d structures
have been mapped but the training data
is very small
no matter what it's like millions maybe
a one or two million or something like
that
but some very small number but like it
doesn't seem like that's scalable
there has to be i don't know it feels
like you want
to somehow 10x the data or 100x the data
somehow
yes but we also can take advantage of
um of uh homology models
right so the models that are of very
good quality because they are
essentially
uh obtained based on the evolutionary
information
right so so you can there is a potential
to enhance this
information and uh you know use it
again uh to to empower the
the uh the training set um
and it's i think i i am actually
very optimistic i think it's been
one of these uh sort of uh
you know uh churning events
where you have a system
that is you know a machine learning
system
that is truly better than the sort of
the
more conventional biophysics based
methods that's a huge leap
this is one of those fun questions but
uh where would you put it in
in the uh ranking of the greatest
breakthroughs in artificial intelligence
history
so like okay so let's let's see who's in
the running
maybe you can correct me so you got like
alpha zero and alpha go
beating you know beating the world
champion at the game of go
thought to be impossible like 20 years
ago
or at least the ad community was highly
skeptical
then you got like also deep blue
original kasparov
you have deep learning itself like the
maybe what would you say the
alexnet image in that moment so the
first
you'll network at achieving human level
performance
super not that's not true
achieving like a big leap in performance
on the computer vision problem uh
there is open ai the whole like gpt-3
that whole space of transformers and
language models just achieving this
incredible
performance uh of application of neural
networks to
language models boston dynamics pretty
cool
like robotics even though people are
like there's no
ai no no there's no machine
learning currently but uh ai is much
bigger than machine learning yes
so so that just the engineering aspect i
would say is one of the greatest
accomplishments in engineering
side engineering meaning like mechanical
engineering
of uh robotics ever then of course
autonomous vehicles you can argue for
waymo
which is like the google self-driving
car or you can
argue for tesla which is like actually
being used by hundreds of thousands of
people
on the road today machine learning
system um
and uh i don't know if you can what else
what else is there but i think that's it
so and then alpha four many people are
saying as
up there potentially number one would
you put them at number one
well in terms of the impact
on on the science and on the society
beyond
it's definitely you know to me would be
one of the
you know uh top three three
i mean i'm probably not the best person
to to
to answer that you know but you know i
uh
you know i i do have i i remember my
you know uh back in i think 1997
when deep blue that kasparov
it was i mean it was a shock
i mean it was and i think for the for
the
you know uh for the
you know uh pre-substantial
part of the world that especially
people who have some uh you know
some experience with chess right and
realizing how
incredibly human this game how you know
how much of a brain power you need
you know to to reach those you know
those levels of
uh grand masters right level and it's
probably one of the first time and
how good caspar was and again yeah so
kasparov is actually one of the best
ever
right and you get a machine that beats
him
right so it's it's first time a machine
probably beat a human at
that scale of a thing of anything yes
yes so that was to me that was like you
know one of the groundbreaking
events in the history of ayat that's
probably number one as
probably like we don't it's hard to
remember it's like muhammad ali versus
uh
i don't know any other mike tyson or
something like that it's like nah
you got to put muhammad ali at number
one uh same with
same with d blue even though it's not
machine learning based
uh i still it uses advanced search
and search is the integral part of the
api yeah right so it's not you said this
people don't think of it that way not
at this moment in vogue currently search
is not seen as a
as a fundamental aspect of intelligence
but it very well
i mean very likely is in fact i mean
that's what neural networks are
they're just performing search on the
space of parameters and it's all search
all of intelligence is some form of
search and you just have to become
clever and clever at that search problem
and i also have uh another one that you
didn't mention that's
that's that's uh one of my favorite ones
is uh so you probably heard of this it's
uh i think it's called
deep rembrandt it's the project where
they
they trained i think there was a
collaboration between
the uh sort of the uh experts in in
rembrandt
uh painting in netherlands and
a group an artificial intelligence group
where they train an algorithm
to replicate the style of the rembrandt
and they
actually printed a a portrait that never
existed before
uh in the style of rembrandt they they
uh
i think they printed it only on a sort
of
uh on the canvas that you know using
pretty much
same types of paints and stuff and to me
it was mind-blowing
yeah it's in the space of art that's
interesting there hasn't been um
maybe that's that's it but i i think
there hasn't been an image in that
moment yet in a space of art
you haven't been able to achieve super
human level performance
in the space of art even though there
was you know there's a
big famous thing where there was a piece
of art was purchased i guess for a lot
of money yes
yeah but it's still you know people are
like in the space of music at least um
that's you know it's clear that human
created pieces
are much more popular so there hasn't
been a moment where it's like
oh this is we're now i would say in the
space of music
what makes a lot of money we're talking
about serious money
it's music and movies or like shows and
so on
and entertainment there hasn't been a
moment where
ai created uh ai was able to create
a piece of music or a piece of
uh cinema like netflix show
that is uh you know that's sufficiently
popular to make
a ton of money yeah and that moment
would be very
very powerful because that's like a
that's in the ai system being used to
make a lot of money and like direct of
course ai tools
like even premiere audio editing all the
editing everything i do
to edit this podcast there's a lot of ai
involved i won't actually this is
a program i want to talk to those folks
just because i want to nerd out it's
called izotope i don't know if you're
familiar with it
they have a bunch of tools of audio
processing and they have
i think they're boston based just it's
so exciting to me
to use it like on the audio here because
it's all machine learning it's not
because most
most audio production stuff
is like any kind of processing you do is
very basic signal processing
and you're tuning knobs and so on they
have all of that of course
but they also have all of this machine
learning stuff like where you actually
give it training data you select parts
of the audio you train on
you you train on it and it it
figures stuff out it's great it's able
to detect
uh like the ability of it to be able to
separate voice and music for example or
voice in anything
is incredible like it it just
it's clearly exceptionally good at uh
you know applying these different neural
networks models to
to just separate the different kinds of
signals from the audio
that that uh okay so that's really
exciting
photoshop adobe people also use it but
to generate
a piece of music yeah that will sell
millions
a piece of art yeah no i agree and you
know it's uh
that's that's you know uh you know
i as i mentioned i offer my my ai class
and you know
an integral part of this is a project
right so it's
it's my favorite ultimate favorite part
because it typically
we have these you know project
presentations the last
two weeks of the classes right before
you know the the christmas break and
it's it's
sort of it adds those cool excitement
and every time i'm i'm amazed you know
with with some
uh some projects that people uh
you know come up with and so uh and
quite a few of them are actually you
know they some
have some link to uh to to arts i mean
you know i think
last year uh we had a group
who designed an ai uh producing uh
hocus japanese poems oh wow
uh so and some of them so you know it
got
trained on the on the english space
hikers hikers right there
so um and and some of them you know
they get to present like the the top
selection they were pretty good
i mean you know i mean of course i'm not
i'm not a specialist but yeah you you
read them
and you see it seems profound yes yeah
it seems
so it's kind of cool we also had a
couple of projects where
people tried to to teach ai how to play
like rock music classical music
uh i think and and and popular music
interestingly enough uh you know
classical music was
among the most difficult ones and and
and you know of course if you
if you know uh you know
if if you look at the you know the uh
like grand masters of music like bach
right so there is a lot of uh there is a
lot of almost math
yeah well he's very mathematical exactly
so so this is i would imagine that
at least some style of this music could
be picked up
but then you have those completely
different spectrum
of of you know classical composers and
so
you know it and you know it's almost
like you know
you don't have to sort of look at the
data you just listen to it and say nah
that's that's that's not it not yet
that's not right yeah
that's that's how i feel too this open
ai has i think open muse or something
like that the system
it's cool but it's like eh it's not
compelling for some for some reason
it could be a psychological reason too
maybe we need to have a human
being a tortured soul behind the music i
don't know
yeah no that absolutely i completely
agree
but yeah whether or not we'll have at
one day we'll have
you know a song written by an ai
engine to to be in like in top
charts yeah musical charts i wouldn't be
surprised
i wouldn't be surprised i wonder if we
already have one
and it just hasn't been announced
we wouldn't know how hard is the
multi-protein folding problem is that
kind of
something you've already mentioned which
is baked into this idea of greater and
greater complexity of proteins
like multi-domain proteins does that
basically become multi-protein
like complexes it's yes you you got it
right so so
it's sort of it has
the components of both of protein
folding
and protein protein interactions
because in order for these domains i
mean many of these
proteins actually they never form a
stable structure
uh you know one of my favorite proteins
you know and uh
pretty much everyone who who works in
the
i know who whom i know who works in the
you know
with proteins they always have their
favorite proteins
right so so one of my favorite proteins
are probably
my favorite protein the one that i
worked when i was a postdoc
is so-called post-synaptic density 95
psd 95 protein
so it's uh it's one of the key
actors in uh in the majority of
neurological processes at the molecular
level so it's a
and it essentially it's a it's a key
player
in the postsynaptic density so this is
the crucial part of this
uh synapse where you know a lot of these
chemoliquor processes are happening
so it's it has five domains
right so five protein dominances so
pretty you know
large proteins uh i think uh 600
something amino acids uh but
you know the way it's organized itself
it's flexible right so it acts as a
scaffold
so it is used to bring
in other proteins so they start
acting in the orchestrated manner
right so and the the type of the shape
of this protein
it's in a way there are some stable
parts of this
protein but there are some flexible and
this flexibility
is built in into the protein in order to
become sort of this
multifunctional machine so do you think
that kind of thing is also learnable
through the alpha fold two kind of
approach
i mean the time will tell
is it another level of complexity is it
is it uh
like how big of a jumping complexity is
that whole thing to me
it's it's yet another level of
complexity because when we talk about
uh protein protein interactions and
there is actually a
a different challenge for this called
capri and so this
that is focus uh specifically on
macromolecular interactions
protein protein for dna etc
so uh but it's you know
there are different mechanisms
uh that govern molecular interactions
and that need to be picked up
say by a machine learning algorithm uh
interestingly enough
we actually we participated uh
for a few years in this competition
we typically don't participate in
competitions
i don't know uh don't have enough time
you know because it's very intensive
yeah yeah it's a very intensive process
but we participated back in
um you know about 10 years ago or so
and the way we enter this competition so
we design a
scoring function right so the function
that evaluates
whether or not your protein protein
interaction is supposed to look like
experimentally solved right so the
scoring function is very critical part
of the of the uh model prediction
so we designed it to be a machine
learning one and so
it was one of the first machine learning
based scoring function
used in capri and uh
you know we essentially you know learned
what
should contribute what are the critical
components contributing
into the protein protein interaction so
this this could be converted into a
learning problem and thereby could be
it could be learned i believe so yes do
you think alpha fold
two or something similar to it from deep
mind or somebody else
will be will result in a nobel prize
or multiple nobel prizes so like the
you know obviously maybe not so
obviously
you can't give a nobel prize to the
computer program
uh you at least for now give it to the
designers of that program
but is do you see one or multiple nobel
prizes
where alpha fold two
is like a large percentage of what that
prize
is given for would it lead to
discoveries at the level of nobel
prizes i mean
i think we are definitely destined to
see the nobel prize
becoming sort of to be evolving
with the evolution of science and the
evolution of science as such
that it now becomes like really
multifaceted right so where you have
you don't really have like a unique
discipline you have sort of the
the a lot of cross disciplinary talks in
order
to achieve uh sort of you know really
big
advancements uh you know
so i think
you know the computational methods will
be
acknowledged in one way or another and
in
as a matter of fact uh you know
they were first acknowledged back in
2013
right where you know the first
three uh people were uh you know
awarded the the nobel prize for the pro
for studying the protein folding right
the principle
and you know i think all three of them
are computational by physicists
right so um you know that
i think is is inavoidable
you know it will come with the time
um the fact that
you know alpha fold and you know similar
approaches because
again it's a matter of time that people
will embrace
the this uh you know principle and
we'll see more and more such uh you know
such tools
coming into play but uh you know these
methods will be critical
in uh in a scientific discovery
no no doubts about it on the engineering
side may be a dark question
but do you think it's possible to use
these machine learning methods to
start to engineer proteins
and the next question is
something quite a few biologists are
against some are for
for study purposes is to engineer
viruses
do you think machine learning like
something like alpha fold could be used
to engineer viruses
so to answering the first question you
know it has been
you know a part of the
research in the protein science the
protein design
is you know is a very prominent
areas of research of course you know one
of the pioneers is david baker and
rosetta
algorithm that you know essentially
was doing the the nova design and was
used
to design new proteins you know and
designer proteins means design of
functions
like when you design a protein you can
control i mean the whole point of the
protein
with the protein structure comes a
function like correct it's doing
something correct
so you can design different things so
you can yeah so you can do
well you can look at the proteins from
the function perspective you can
also look at the proteins from the
structure perspective right so the
structural building blocks
so if you want to have a building block
of a certain shape
you can try to achieve it yes by you
know introducing a new pro
protein sequence and predicting you know
uh how it will fold
so uh so with that i mean it's it's a
natural
uh one of the you know natural uh
applications of these algorithms
now talking about engineering
a virus with machine learning with
machine learning right so so
well um you know
so luckily for us i mean uh we don't
have
that much data right
uh we actually uh right now one of the
projects that we are uh
carrying on in the lab is we
we're trying to develop a machine
learning algorithm that
uh determines the uh whether or not the
the current strain is pathogenic
and the current strain of the
cardiovirus of the one of the virus i
mean so there are applications to
coronaviruses because we have strains of
sarskov2 also sarskovi
mers that are pathogenic but we also
have strains
of other coronaviruses that are you know
not
pathogenic i mean the the common cold
viruses and
you know and some other ones right so so
pathogenic meaning spreading oh but
pathogenic
means actually inflicting damage
correct uh there are also some you know
seasonal versus pandemic strains of
influenza
right and to determining the what are
the molecular determinant
right so that are built in into the
protein sequence into the
gene sequence right so and uh whether or
not the machine learning can
determine those deter those components
right oh interesting so like using
machine learning to do that's really
interesting to
to to given give the input is like uh
what the entire sequence the protein
sequence and then determine if this
thing is going to be able to do damage
to to uh to a biological system yeah
so so i mean good machine learning
you're saying we don't have enough data
for that
we i mean for for this specific one we
do uh we might
actually uh you know have to back up on
this because we're still in the process
there was uh one uh work uh that
appeared in by archive by eugene kunin
who is one of these you know pioneers in
in in
evolutionary genomics uh and they
tried to look at this uh but uh you know
the the methods were sort of
standard uh you know supervised learning
uh
methods uh and now the question is
you know can you you know advance it
further by by using you know not so
standard methods
you know so there's obviously a lot of
hope in in transfer learning
where you can actually try to transfer
the information that the
machine learns about the proper protein
sequences
right and you know so so there is
some promise in going this direction but
if we have this
it would be extremely useful because
then we could essentially forecast
the potential mutations that would make
the current strain
more or less pathogenic and anticipate
anticipate them exactly from a vaccine
development for the treatment the anti
any viral drug development that would be
a very crucial task
but you could also use that system
to then say how would we potentially
modify
this virus to make it more pathogenic
this that's true that's true i mean uh
you know the again
the hope is well several things right so
one
is that you know it's even if you design
a you know a sequence right
so to carry out the actual
experimental biology to ensure that
all the common components working you
know
is is a completely different matter
difficult process yes
uh then they did you know uh we've seen
in the past there could be some
regulation of the
the moment the scientific community
recognizes that it's now
becoming no longer a sort of a a fun
puzzle to
you know for for machine learning it
could be yeah so so then there might be
some regulation
so i i think back in what 2015
there was you know the there was the
issue on regulating the
uh the research on um on influenza
strains right that there were
you know several groups uh you know use
surfaces
mutation analysis to to determine uh
whether or not this strain will
jump from one species to another and i
think there was like a
half a year more moratorium on on the
research on on the paper
published until you know uh scientists
you know analyzed it and decided that
it's actually safe
um i forgot what that's called something
a function testing function
function gain a function yeah and gain a
functional loss of function that's right
sorry
uh it's it's like let's watch this thing
mutate for a while to see
like to see what kind of things we can
observe
i guess i'm not so much worried about
that kind of research if there's a lot
of regulation
and if it's done very well and with with
competence and seriously
i am more worried about kind of this
uh you know the the the underlying
aspect of this question is more like 50
years from now
speaking to the drake equation one one
of the parameters in the drake equation
is how long civilizations last
and that's that seems to be the most
important value actually for calculating
if there's other alien
intelligence civilizations out there
that's where there's most variability
uh assuming like if life if that
percentage
that life can emerge is like not
zero like if we're super unique then
it's the
how long we last is basically the most
important thing
so from from a selfish perspective but
also from a drake
uh equation perspective i'm worried
about the la our civilization
lasting and you kind of think about all
the ways in which machine learning can
be used to design
greater weapons of destruction
right and i mean one way to ask
that if you look sort of 50 years from
now 100 years from now
would you be more worried about natural
pandemics
or engineered pandemics
like who's who is the better designer of
viruses
nature or humans if we look down the
line
i i think uh in my view i would still be
worried about the
natural pandemics simply because i mean
the
the capacity uh of
the nature producing yeah this it does
pretty
good job right yes and the motivation
for
using virus engineering viruses for uh
as a weapon
is a weird one because uh maybe you can
correct me on this but it's very
it seems very difficult to target a
virus right the whole point of a weapon
the way a rocket works
if a starting point you have an end
point and you're trying to hit a target
to hit a target with a virus is very
difficult it's basically just
right it it's the target would be the
human species
oh man yeah i have a i have a hope in us
i'm
forever optimistic that we will not
there's no
there's insufficient evil in the world
to do to lead that to that kind of
destruction
well you know i also hope that i mean
that's what we see
i mean uh with the way we are getting
connected
the world is getting connected i think
it it helps
for the world to become more transparent
yeah so so the information spread
is you know i think it's one of the key
things for the for the society
to become more balanced yeah one way or
another this is something that people
disagree with me on but
i do think that the kind of secrecy that
governments have
so you're kind of speaking more to the
other aspects like
research community being more open
companies are being more open uh
government is still like
we're talking about like military
secrets yeah i think i think military
secrets
of the kind that could destroy the world
will become also a thing of the 20th
century
it'll become more and more open yeah
like i
i think nations will lose power in the
21st century like
lose sufficient power towards secrecies
transparency is more beneficial than
secrecy
but of course it's not obvious let's
hope so
let's hope so that that you know the the
the
uh the governments will become
more transparent what so we last talked
i think in march or april
what have you learned how has your
philosophical
psychological biological worldview
changed since then or you've been
studying it non-stop
from a computational biology perspective
how is your understanding and thoughts
about this fire has changed over those
months
from the beginning to today one thing
that uh i was
really amazed at how efficient
the scientific community was i mean and
uh you know
even just judging uh on on this
very narrow domain of you know uh
protein structure
and understanding the structural uh
characterization of of this virus from
the components point of view of the
you know whole wireless point of view
you know
if you look at at sars right
the the something that happened you know
oh less than 20 but you know close
enough
20 years ago and you see what
you know when it happened you know what
was sort of the response to
by the scientific community you see that
the the structure characterizations
did a cure but it took
several years right now
the things that took several years it's
a matter of months
right so so we we see that you know the
the the
research pop up we are at the
unprecedented level in terms of the
sequencing
right never uh before we had
a single virus sequence so many times
you know so which allows us to actually
to trace very precisely
the sort of the evolutionary
nature of this virus what happens and
it's not just
the you know this virus independently
of everything is you know it's the you
know the the sequence of this virus
linked anchored to the specific
geographic place
to specific people because you know the
the
our genotype influences also
you know the the evolution of this you
know it's it's always a
horse pathogen co evolution that that
you know occurs it'd be cool if we also
had
a lot more data about sort of the spread
of this virus
not maybe well it'd be nice if we had it
for like contact tracing purposes
for this virus but it would be also nice
if we had it for the study for future
viruses
to be able to respond and so on but it's
already nice that we have geographical
data and the
basic data from individual humans yeah
exactly i know i think
context racing is is is obviously
a key uh component in understanding
the spread of this virus uh we there is
also there is a number of challenges
right so xprice
is one of them we we you know uh
just recently the you know took a part
of
this competition it's the prediction of
the
uh of the uh number of
infections in different regions so
and you know obviously the the ai
is the main topic in those predictions
yeah but it's still the data i mean
that's that's a competition but the
the data is weak on the training
like it's it's great it's much more than
probably before but like
it would be nice if it was like really
rich i
i i talked to michael mina from uh from
harvard
i mean he dreams that the community
comes together with like a weather map
to wear of viruses right like
really high resolution sensors on like
how from person to person the viruses
that travel all the different kinds of
viruses right because there's
there's there's a ton of them and then
you'll be able to tell the story
that uh you've spoken about of the
evolution of these viruses like
day-to-day
mutations that are occurring i mean that
would be fascinating
just uh from perspective study and from
the perspective of being able to respond
to future pandemics that's ultimately
what i'm
worried about um people love books uh
is there is there some three
or whatever number of books technical
fiction philosophical that
uh that brought you joy in life had an
impact on your life
and maybe some that you would recommend
others
so i'll give you three very different
books and i also have a special
runner-up
uh and a honorable match yeah
it's a yeah i wouldn't i mean it's it's
an audiobook and that's the
yeah there's some specific reason behind
it okay so
uh you know so the first book is you
know something that uh
sort of impacted my earlier stage of
life and
i probably are not gonna be very
original here uh
it's bulgakov's master and margarita so
that's probably
you know well not for russian maybe it's
not super original but it's
you know it's it's a really powerful
book for uh even in english
so i write it in english so it is
incredibly powerful and
i mean it's the the way it ends
right so it's it's i i i still have
goosebumps when i read the
the the very last sort of the it's
called prologue
where uh it's just so powerful what
impact did you
have on you what ideas what insights did
you get from it i was just
taken by you know by the
the fact that you have
those parallel lives
apart from many centuries right and
somehow
they they got sort of interwined into
one story and
and that's to me was fascinating and
uh you know of course the the romantic
part of this
book it's like you know it's not just
you know romance it's like
the romance empowered by sort of magic
right
and and that and and and and maybe
on top of that you have some irony which
inavoidable right so because it
it was that you know this is the soviet
time but it's very it's very it's deeply
russian so that's
um the the wit the humor and the pain
the the love all of that is um one of
the books that kind of
captures something about russian culture
that people outside of russia should
probably read i agree what's uh what's
the section so so the second one is
again another one that uh it happened
uh i read it uh later in my life i think
uh
i read it first time when i was a a
a graduate student and that's uh the
solzhenitsyn's uh
cancer ward that is
an amazingly powerful book it's what is
it about
it's about i mean essentially based on
on
uh you know seljunitsen uh uh was
diagnosed with cancer when
he was reasonably young and he he made a
full recovery
but uh you know so so this is about a
a a person who was sentenced for life
in one of these you know camps
and he had some cancer
so he was uh you know transported back
to one of these
uh uh soviet republics i think it was
you know south asian uh republics and
uh the the book is about
you know his experience
being a a prisoner being
a you know a patient in the cancer
clinic in a cancer ward surrounded by
people many of which
die right but
in a way you know the way i you know it
reads i mean first of all
later on i i uh read the the accounts of
the
of the doctors who described these
you know the the experiences uh you know
uh in the book by the patient
as as incredibly accurate
right so so you know i i read that there
was you know some doctors saying that
you know
every single doctor should read this
book to understand
what the patient feels but
you know again as many of the social
media
sergey nissan's books it has multiple
levels of complexity
and obviously the the you know if you
look above
the cancer and the patient i mean the
the the humor that was growing
and then disappeared in in
in his uh you know uh in his body with
some consequences
i mean this is you know allegorically
the soviet yeah
and and you know and he actually he he
agree you know when he was
asked he said that this is what make him
think about this you know how to combine
these experiences
him being a part of the you know of the
soviet regime
also being a part of the of the you know
of
someone sent to the to gulag camp
right and also someone who who
experienced cancer in his life
you know the uh the good luck
archipelago
and this book these are the works that
actually made him uh you know receive a
nobel prize
but you know to me i i've uh you know
i've read different other uh you know uh
books by solzhenitsyn this one is to me
is
the most powerful one that and by the
way both this one and the previous one
you write in russian
yes yes so now there is the third book
is is an english book and it's
completely different so so you know
we're
switching the gears completely so this
is the book
which it's not even a book it's a it's
an essay
by uh jonathan neumann called the
computer and the brain and that was the
thing the book he was writing knowing
that
he he was dying of cancer so so the book
was released
back it's a very thin book right but
uh the the power
the intellectual power in in this book
in this essay
is incredible i mean you probably know
that von neumann
is considered to be one of these biggest
thinkers right so the his intellectual
power
was incredible right and you can
actually
feel this power in this book where you
know the person is writing knowing that
he will be
you know he will die the book actually
got published only after his death back
in
1958 he died in 1957
and but so so he tried to put as many
ideas
that you know he still did you know uh
hadn't realized and
you know so so this book is very
difficult to read
because you know every single paragraph
is just compact you know is is
filled with this ideas and you know the
ideas are incredible
um even nowadays you know so so he tried
to put the parallels
between the brain computing power
the neural system and the computers
you know as they were here he was
working on this like approximately
57 57. so so that was right during his
you know when he was diagnosed with
cancer and he was essentially
yeah he's one of those um there's a few
folks
people mention i think ed whitton is
another that like
everybo everyone that meets them they
say he's just an intellectual powerhouse
yes okay so who's the honorable mention
so and this is i mean the reason i put
it sort of in this
separate section because this is a book
that i
reasonably recent uh uh recently
listened to
so so it's an audio book and this is a
book called
lab girl by hope jaron so hope jaren
is she is a a scientist
she is a geo chemist that essentially
studies
um the uh the fossil
uh plants and so she uses the this
fossil and the the chemical analysis to
understand
what was the climate
back in you know in thousand years
hundreds of thousands of years ago and
so
something that incredibly touched me by
this book
it was narrated by the author nice
and it's excellent incredibly personal
story incredibly so
certain parts of the book you could
actually
hear the author crying and that to me i
mean i i never experienced anything like
this
you know reading the book but it was
like you know
the the connection between you and the
author
and i think this is you know this is
really
a must read but even better must
listen to uh audiobook for
anyone who wants to learn about sort of
you know academia science
research in general because it's a very
personal account about
her uh becoming a scientist
so uh we're just before new year's
you know we talked a lot about some
difficult topics of viruses and so on do
you have some
exciting things uh you're looking
forward to in 2021
some new year's resolutions may be silly
or fun
or something very important and
fundamental to
the world of science or something
completely unimportant
well well i'm i'm definitely looking
forward
to towards you know things becoming
normal
right so uh yes so i i really miss
traveling uh every summer
i go to a international summer school is
called the school for molecular and
theoretical biology
it's held in europe and it's organized
by very good friends of mine
and this is a cool the school for gifted
kids
from all over the world and they're
incredibly bright it's like every time i
go there it's like you know it's
it's it's it's a highlight of the year
um and you know we couldn't
make it this august so we we did this
school
remotely but it's it's different it's so
some i am uh
definitely looking for it next august
coming there
i also i mean you know one of the one of
my
you know personal resolutions i i
realized that you know
being in you know in-house and working
from from home um
you know i realized that that actually
i apparently missed a lot
you know spending time with my family
believe it or not so so you you
typically you know
with all the research and uh you know
and and teaching and everything really
related to the academic life uh i mean
you get distracted and so so uh you know
you don't
feel that you know the fact that you are
away from your family
doesn't affect you because you are you
know naturally distracted by other
things
and uh you know this time i i realized
that you know that that's
so important right spending your time
with the with the family with your kids
and so i'm that that would be my new
year resolution
and actually trying to spend as much
time as possible
even when the world opens up yeah that's
a that's a beautiful message that's a
beautiful
reminder i asked you if uh
if there's a russian poem you could read
uh that i could force you to read and he
said okay fine sure
uh do you mind do you mind reading and
you're like you said that
no paper needed so nope so yeah so the
this poem
was written by my namesake another
dmitry dimitri
kemirfeldt um and uh is a
you know it's a recent poem and it's uh
it's called uh sorceress vedima
uh in in russian uh or actually
call dunya so that's sort of another
sort of connotation of sorceress or
which and i really like it and it's one
of
just a handful poems i actually can
recall by heart
i also have a very strong association
when i read this poem with uh master
margarita
the the the main female character
margarita and also it's
you know it's about you know it's
happening about
the same time we're talking uh now so
around new year around christmas
you mind uh reading
that's beautiful i love how it captures
a a moment
of longing and uh
maybe love even yes to me it has a lot
of meaning
about you know this something that
is happening something that is far away
but still very close to you
and yes it's the the winter
the way there's something magical about
winter isn't it what is
the well i don't know i don't know how
to translate it but uh but a
kiss in winter uh is interesting uh
lips and winter and all that kind of
stuff it's beautiful i mean
russian has a way as a reason russian
poetry is just
i'm a fan of poetry in both languages
but english
doesn't capture some of the magic that
russian seems to so
thank you for doing that that was
awesome dmitry
is great to talk to you again you're uh
it's contagious how much you love what
you do how much you love life
so i really appreciate you taking the
time to talk today
and thank you for having me thanks for
listening to this conversation with
demetri corkin
and thank you to our sponsors brave
browser
netsuite business management software
magic spoon low carb cereal
and a sleep self cooling mattress
so the choice is browsing privacy
business success
healthy diet a comfortable sleep choose
wisely my friends
and if you wish click the sponsor links
below to get a discount and to support
this podcast
now let me leave you with some words
from jeffrey eugenides
biology gives you a brain life
turns it into a mind thank you for
listening and hope to see you
next time
you